joining me here right now on the rich
eisen show is a man who played several
seasons in the national football he's an
expert on offensive line play and i just
love
following him on twitter and he's got a
terrific podcast of his own called jeff
schwartz is smarter than you jeff
schwartz back here on the rich either
show how are you jeff
i am fantastic thanks for being back all
right what'd you make of the thursday
night game what do you got for me
so every every thursday night game that
we dread ends up being terrific by the
way it happens every single time oh my
god the panthers in texas are playing
next thursday night that game will be
great uh look very simple the giant
should have won that game right um
daniel jones played maybe the the best
complete game he has since he's got the
nfl right his rushing his passing the
giant offensive line played really well
in the second half of that game against
the washington defense that we expected
a lot from this year and guess what they
still lost right like you you just
can't lose games like that in the nfl
it's what bad teams do
and we keep waiting for the giants to
not be bad anymore they have the most
losses in the nfl since 2017. the start
of that they the most in the nfl they're
like 18 and 49 or something in that time
span um they play bad football and we
saw last night in big moments they
played the worst football right they
they forced a turnover
uh a great
brethren great play right he jumps the
route he gets the ball and what do they
do they take 11 seconds off the clock
yards to get your field goal and then
they come out obviously and how do you
jump off you're literally looking at the
ball if you're the zero technique
essentially on the center you're not
blocking that kick buddy i'm just
letting you know as someone who did feel
gold protection forever you ain't
blocking that kick i'm just letting you
know and you jumped outside like
things like that cannot happen
especially
when
the coach joe judge brands himself as
this like disciplinarian and and we're
not going to make mistakes and and then
in week one joe just throws a challenge
flag on a scoring review play that gets
they get you know they they get uh they
get challenged automatically like you
keep making mistakes and we keep being
told that this is a different giants
team i haven't seen it yet so if you're
a giants fan you have every right to be
upset this morning about your team after
last night well what is the um
assessment of the offense the play
calling the the number of x's and o's
people
that i follow on twitter and i consider
you one of them too jeff
very critical of
jason garrett's system and offense and
not being diverse enough which is what
we heard all the time in dallas for all
those years
as well uh is that an accurate charge
cause i mean the first 15 last night
looked pretty good and daniel jones did
play as you point out a complete game he
was running free without a holding
penalty calling it back i mean put it
all together i mean slayton was wide
open i mean how much of this can be put
on
garrett when it's all said and done
i'm not sure last night was was really
garrett's fault i mean i think we look
at the end of the game situation where
again they wasted a whole 11 seconds and
keep the field goal and you know people
put that on jason garrett but that
really comes back to philosophy of the
coach right the coach wants to be
aggressive there then i would imagine
that that would be radioed into the
offense to be more aggressive i do think
the giants are generally
um you're pretty
a pretty boring offense right they're
not very imaginative um uh but they've
drafted to be that way right they
dropped a running back they dropped a
quarterback who is not i think in his
best is average the nfl um that's what
their offense is gonna be
with the personnel they have and i know
it's frustrating for giants fans
but you you signed it off at the
coordinator who was that way in dallas
right like what do you expect the the
thing we do in the nfl which is um i
guess normal nature to think that
coaches are going to just change who
they are and some do right andy reid has
done a good job with that bill boxer has
always been been adaptable but jason
garrett has been there for a long time
his offense at the end of his time in
dallas was pretty boring and yet you
know the giant guess what's still pretty
boring like what do we expect this to be
that's who he is that's what his
philosophy is um you know just kind of
conservative run the ball don't make
mistakes which is fine you should win
some games doing that
but you have to be dynamic on offense
now that's not what the giants are
so did you do you really think daniel
jones at his best is average i mean
because he he has above average skills
don't you think i mean
he can be a two-way threat you know and
the same way that we're in rightfully so
saying like say ryan tannehill's praises
i mean jones has the same game in in
many ways he's fa he's fast and he's
elusive and if he's accurate and he's
thrown almost 64
of his balls hasn't thrown an
interception yet i mean those are
numbers i would take if i'm the giants
for the first two games
of the season wouldn't you
no i mean
i mean it's so
you just laid out a bunch of ifs right
if i did no i didn't if he's uh if he's
this if he's that i mean that doesn't
feel like a quarterback who uh okay is
where do you put garrett carr as a
quarterback in the
nfl yeah i mean i could see where you're
going i know where you're putting it but
i mean
there are occasions where he'll play a
game where he misses on like what two
passes and he's the perfect vessel for
whatever gruden's cooking up and then
he'll throw a ball behind somebody when
they're wide open on a crossing route
you know and and if he puts it in front
of him that's 25 yards and instead now
we're second and ten or third and ten
you know and i i get what you're saying
i'm just i guess talking about a skill
set like if at his best
he should be daniel jones should be a
guy who can put some points on the board
and last night
my god they could have put up 40 if they
didn't have those mistakes you know i
mean that could have been against the
defense that we all consider i think in
the nfl media as as a a a pretty stout
one don't you think that's but that's
what sets apart kind of the good from
the great right is not having those
moments right slain is wide open and i
thought tory smith was one tweet out
they thought that ball was just half a
you know half a pace overthrown and
maybe it was i mean i'm not gonna argue
with him he's played wide receiver for
many years nfl you know but again like
does does pat mahomes overthrow that guy
right he's a bad example he's the best
quarterback but you know this yes derek
carr would throw that guy probably not
right like it's little plays like that
that are made
by the upper echelon quarterbacks
they're just not made by guys like
daniel jones and it's unfair to point to
one throw in that game but often those
throws are the ones that make you the
money right those are the throws that
and the best example for this by the way
i i'm gonna use this until the end of
time
is the 20 is the 2019 super bowl right
jimmy garoppolo the reason why they
dropped the tree land there were two
plays in the fourth quarter one kills
wide open on third down doesn't throw to
him now to play design to go to kittle
this doesn't do it someone else sanders
incomplete and then again on the next
drive there's open for a touchdown the
play is perfectly drawn up perfectly
executed balls overthrown by three yards
it's like it's two or three throws a
game that set apart the average to the
above average and so far daniel jones to
me hasn't shown any ability to be that
above average quarterback jeff schwartz
eight years in the nfl um joining me
here and on the rich i showed you get
that number right i know that you you
were i got that number right right your
eight-year veteran nine-year-old veteran
what are you yeah hey yeah you got that
right okay and so the the washington
football team they got do they have
their guy taylor heinecke what do you
think is he the guy yeah i don't know i
have some washington football team fans
that are using back and forth like
throughout the game about this too right
like every quarter we updated it it's
honestly the guy um i think that
historically speaking the answer would
be no right um you don't have a lot of
players like him that end up being
franchise type quarterbacks and there's
a reason why they brought in ryan
fitzpatrick they thought that he's just
a good backup and you know not really a
certain quarterback type but he played
well last night um and i think just we
need to see more there's only third
start um we need to see more of i
wouldn't mean to know just because again
that just the nfl isn't kind to
quarterbacks that have his background um
but there's always outliers but i don't
i'm not sure he's the out this is a 17
now 16 now i mean that's
that doesn't feel like a guy who's a
franchise quarterback all right so what
game are you looking forward to this
weekend jeff
which game you're looking for um well of
course you know chiefs ravens i'm
looking forward to that one i think the
chiefs uh are are gonna go in there and
score a lot of points again because they
are
this the ravens just don't adjust very
well to what the chiefs do on offense
and um you know starting 0-2
used to be the end of your season
essentially now this year because of 17
games it might not be right that's uh
that's you know it's something to think
about as we go into this year i think
another game is located in the niners
and eagles or eagles offensively i
watched a bunch of that game only
because
i foolishly been on the falcons as usual
and uh
and uh and eagles eagles offense looked
good i was like their offense lines back
and healthy her defensive line was
rushing to pass her well uh you know
hertz was efficient he got the ball
we're supposed to be a little bit of
kind of college-esque offense feel to it
but he looked pretty good and i get
niners team obviously often embarrassing
final three minutes of alliance game um
if the eagles win this game
um a lot of us might have to change our
opinion on what jalen hurt can be so
that's a kind of a low-key interesting
game uh because the nine ourselves
didn't finish very well uh which was
they'll come out kind of hot but i'm
kind of looking forward to seeing eagles
offense you know what uh here on the
rich isis show jeff when you you go
higher register it means you don't you
know you need to go there to believe
what you're saying i think you just went
higher register on the entire
philadelphia eagles but i'll be honest
uh with washington to see i know with
the watch one more time with the
washington football team
having their backup despite him looking
like he did last night uh they still
should have lost the game the giants
being on two again and the cowboys
coming into the the new stadium here to
take on a chargers team that looked
terrific against washington
and they're being banged up on their
offensive line now and defensive line um
or they're they're they've got lyle
collins out and obviously banged up on
their defensive line
the eagles could uh i just want higher
registers through that the eagles could
uh you know be two and oh and and and
have a nice start to this season for the
nfc so i hear you yeah they they could
um i was hiring the cowboys this year
and unfortunately it feels like another
thorsten to do as usual um you know
they're just uh kind of reckless
injuries and suspensions and stuff so
yeah the eagles if they get to a quick
two-and-oh uh two-nothing lead on on a
division obviously you have to feel good
about about the direction you're in i
think a lot of people
made fun of that higher it felt like a
higher that was made just kind of at the
mouthpiece for the front office uh but
if they go 2-0 obviously the eagles will
be laughing everyone right now is during
the season you could take stock in a
rookie quarterback which one would you
take stock in only one which one you
take stock in
only one um long term play i
i will do
trey lamp and i'll tell you why okay
because he has the best offensive
coordinator of all five of those guys
and when you plan that offense you
succeed right everyone who has played in
a shanahan office
has had success whether you are an
average straight quarterback or above
average straight and rogers mvp last
year
most often that offense is run with guys
who have average traits because it's
it's a it's a stable offense to run um
and treylan says above average straight
doesn't play very much football but he
has above average physical traits and
you give him the opportunity to play in
an office assuming that him and shanahan
are paired together for a long time
moving forward i think he will have the
best
career because of that that doesn't mean
that the other guys are going to suck
but the offensive corner situation in
washington is just much better than is
in chicago might not have matt maggie
moving forward right what is zach wilson
and the jets urban meyer how long is he
gonna stay there um and you know i i
matt jones is is in a good spot with
belichick and with uh and with joshua i
just don't think he has the physical
traits that lance does how's your
brother how's mitchell
jeff he's putting out cooking videos
once a week and he's got a little daily
he's got a little daily videos on
breaking down film he seems to be
enjoying his uh his uh his season so far
okay what i mean i know you want to
speak for him but i mean is he feeling
all right i mean are we are we going to
see him again you think
look he's he's his his line is he is
still rehabbing and he is uh
i'm sure teams have called i would be
foolish if i didn't call like i'm sure
the ravens probably got on the phone
monday night like hey mitch how you
feeling are you healthy to play right um
and so
i don't know what he wants to do he
might just wait till half of your season
and just play half season i i don't know
i know teams have called um but he's
just enjoying life right now well and i
i called you this week jeff schwartz
because you're an oregon duck and i
watched your team just absolutely just
lay some wood in columbus ohio last week
and and we were looking for our
uh toughest player on planet earth award
winner and we spoke to alex forsyth
you're like yeah that would be a good
choice and you know and you also
counseled like look you know it's a unit
offensive line and we're giving them for
ev all of them getting free glue but
what a kid we really enjoyed getting to
meet him um
jeff i mean he was really pretty really
cool talking to the center of the oregon
ducks and alex forsyth
uh the oregon offensive line coach said
he's the like the most mentally tough
player he's ever coached um and you know
he donated the money uh to his dad's
foundation right the more his
scholarship foundation so um he's a he's
a great dude he anchors an offensive one
obviously that was a huge win for our
program and then your wolverines took
down washington so you you know you and
oregon are the
leaders of the alliance so far um yes we
are
yes we're yeah
washington scored a total of 17 points
all season great great start for the
huskies uh this year uh so yeah it was
it was awesome to see oregon get that
recognition um and look we got stony
brook tomorrow
come on don't even go
don't even you can't even finish the
sentence don't even what's with stony
brook what's up come on i watched this i
watched the stony brook new hampshire
highlight on youtube yeah everybody from
week one and my my first thought was
organ might injure everyone on stony
brook
it's just like not a good d2 team or
whatever division they're in um
i feel bad for stony brook but what's i
mean all right it's just okay
oregon stony brook the matchup nobody
saw coming or ever really needed or is
that off the board jeff can we bet on
that like what's the line
so it's funny it's not on the board
right now there is there is a game out
west um there's cal and in sac state and
talis started off the last two games up
two scores and i've lost both of them i
want a bet cal first half but i can't
find a line so so far so
waiting i think i'm patiently waiting oh
my god you're waiting jeff jeff and i
are kindred spirits
yeah
first half watch so jeff schwartz who's
got a podcast saying jeff schwartz is
smarter than you
is admitting that he's spending part of
his time as a human being on this planet
a watching stony brook what was it new
hampshire highlights
right there's a four minute highlight on
youtube i do i do daily practical radios
no i know you've got a gig and you have
a life jeff that's why i was pointed
that's why i was that's where i was
going that you're saying that you're
looking for cal sac state first half
lines to bet on
uh and and and you've got stuff going on
um
not up yet unfortunately
come on give me that give me the first
half give me the first half line people
anything like 14 i'm all over everybody
should at jeff schwartz
g-e-o-f-f shorts thank you very much
jeff schwartz appreciate the time you'd
be welcome
jeff schwartz everybody
yeah
who knew jeff schwartz my long-lost
brother
well you met him here you've met her
here hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here